олег дізнається на мюнхенський турботи
конференції влада а провокація
міжнародного називаю 2 почати курок у
реабілітації путіна для тебе санкції з
російської федерації і діалог з
Російської Федерації там пропасть його все
ще до ідентичності українців та українців
навіть добрий і щедрий жаночка позиція чистий
на делегації закриваючи і Петра Порошенка
зупан його цю провокацію вин крові вище
30 за зустріччю з нашими партнерами для
того, щоб
зупан цієї сури абілітації путіна та Петро
і мати сантин режим проти російської
федерації
ще викл і колос пусту істерику
кремля та автора бті та провокації прийме
ну а ще нацю від цих 12 термінів у і
повний вигляд суть несучи реакції влада
президента України міністерство
закордонних довідка ревнивого парламенту
кітель ще так сама не відро і бувала
на провокацію до прозвучало всім і залі
суду так дзвонова за родом на москві по
передньої руки на подібних парадах марші
валу йти дивізії столітті воюють на донбасі
у тому числі і танкова псковська дивізія
хто розстрілював наших героїв знає та
кадило військам і пити дебальцеве та від
вашим бурчанням
цер'єна єрж езра до українського солдата
і ризикового я ви немов свого бурхливий
протест в тому числі
дима карен вид-во парламенту петелька
ще дозволяють подібні провокації та
запалили припускаючи саму думку вино снуд
овочу українські депутати може сидить і
бурять із путіним
які продажі анексію криму та окупацію
донбаса все колір буває в праду 6
речнику окупації криму в рунеті баку
ще президент зелінський, а в мюнхен не
що заявив йобан маніяку і чи стратегії
хто movin' bro hug вибрати а пройшло то
що потрібно просто перестати стріляти
свобода наша стратегія і закінчиться я
вина а його так ти кцс
або патрулі українських лискова службу
вівці та поліції з бойовиками та з рада рада
нашої армії
і успіхи стрибнемо ця дивні нас правді
виробляє до елементації анексії
крима та окупації донбасу владна
серце ясна хочу сказати відбувається
на кшталт 6 річкові ти анексії криму і
надвоє вже для значень на д.б.
баб'якового адвоката януковичем і чому
згорну тиса до наших партнерів напів
позиції таку ініціативу та спиною заявок
і наземним партнерам ще дано участь
експертів та наземних за для
легітимізації то у фарс тупить
званого для значення карим листя
db-1 kremlin ства парламентом з рота і
мазь з ініціатива та право з ти через
чужого та засідання парламенту the water
не для того, щоб прийняте 2-го жив або
постанови
заява Верховної Ради стягнеш вузьку
річковий майданчик євромайдану і так само
свердління верховної ради
постали команд усіх фракцій диво
анексії крима року наша битва то
потрібно тільки ще зарості справджується з
спробую час писати і нашу на літню
історію ви знаєте брехню by бабикова
розкрила і журналісти так само як і
брехню банківську венозну так зла на вигляд
лагодження в екзотичній краї не обман і
владна а в мережі історії про тещу то
була робочої візи уникати в теперішньому та
важливим путінці був вид безодню
то ти витратила тримаючи мені вантажник не по
трапу на все-всі брехню породила банку
адже очевидно супер ства вимагає
банківська правда вони брехні а ми допомагаємо
і від влади просто ти нас тут на свободу
слова простіше вже говорила моя галаслива лялька
зрозуміла на контракті у кати всі закони
протеза інформацію з проби махати патче
камуї і державному онуку в ту ж
шкіри нас пробу попереднього
свободу слова ну і владно так само
такий же спробуй від esc на опозицію за
крим про спроба кримінальних справ проти
safe f1 і наші втрати та марусі зв раббі
владне
ще 100 суеца нижня київ
сосина ми ти ж не я хочу ще раз ви
значить і позицію європейської
солідарності по землі, щоб тут навіть не
було інформації та спекуляцій колега
європейська солідарність за ринок землі
лами категорично ставок і базару та
розбазарювання української землі і до
рибам біля річки ви намиваєте і складно
ніхто не знаю ким буде закон кінсі яму
результаті допомоги всієї поправки про
позитиві відкривання все нам вас таню
хлинів каїну текіс поправки акімови у
закон це нас правдиво за ну 8
мільйонів державної землі і ми поважаємо
ще про задам зеленський так сам у нього
кінна свій вибір чаю білянка це моя
набити на кадастр земельний земельний
банк за побіжимо ще до христа ради
частини землі мінімальна ціна до сьогодні
встановлена ​​селян вони будуть запікати ну
продавати землю на особі роботі для того
щоб розбазарити державу на землю ми
категорично проти слова і ви мага йому
вигляд вас порожньо тут за ви біжіть за
крима
так ти можеш заявити селянам продавати та
землю алізарин привід дякую в новому будинку